As a patient who has been using the right for six weeks now and having issues with my
colostomy, liquid output for weeks, very fast, sometimes six a day, could this be a part of
detoxing, trying to figure out why, starting a probiotic, any suggestions would be appreciated.
Okay, so whether you're having bowel-waste calota of a colostomy, tube and bag, or into the toilet,
you have to investigate, you know, you know, if there's a change in consistency, why that is. So
so, search at least looking at possible intestinal infection would be good, you know, I wouldn't
necessarily jump to like parasites or anything like that, but looking at infection would be very
appropriate. Both common intestinal infection would be H. Pylori, followed by other bacterial
infections, or uncommon intestinal infections. Could it be something as simple as just imbalance and
inflammatory process, poida, yes. So food sensitivities, gluten issues, dairy issues are your most
kind of things. So looking at diet, investigating that, doing a Syrex 2, Syrex 3, Syrex 4, or Syrex 10
array would look at food sensitivities and things. You could certainly do a stool sample test.
You want to investigate. So those are the things that you would look at for a change in bowel habits.
What is going on? Certainly if you don't have the finances to do the test, you have to experiment with
maybe, you know, a diet that's, you know, you're you're taking things out of your diet to see if there's
if there's something that you're eating that is causing this. Yeah, you have to do some trial and
error of those because running some labs are would be appropriate. I hope that, you know, your oncologist
is recommended regular CBCs and complete metabolic panel because that can tell you right there.
If you do a CBC and you have white blood cell count, that's over 7.0. They'll say it's normal, but
you definitely have an infection going on somewhere. So, and then if your symptoms are
bowel related, you could, you know, make it assumption that baby that's where I have an infection
that I have to deal with. So, if you do have a bacterial infection in the gut, you know,
from the medical standpoint, they're going to probably recommend antibiotics. If you do that,
if you absolutely have to be taking probiotics, it's going to throw off your microbiota. But if you have
a, if you're more inclined to do an alternative approach, thinking of like burberry and garlic and
things like that would be more appropriate from the actual perspective to try to deal with this.